غرقوا المدن سيناريو متكرر ضحاياه كثر في
قارات مختلفه كل ذلك بفعل الاقتضاض
السكاني والمباني الشاهقه والتغيرات
المناخيه مدينه نيويورك الامريكيه او
التفاحه الكبيره كما توصف هي مهدده بالغرق
اما المتسبب في الكارثه المحتمله فناطحات
السحاب التي تميزها فالوزن التراكمي
للمدينه يصل ثقله الى 1.68 ترليون رطل
ويغرقها بنحو مليمتر الى مليمترين سنويا
وفق دراسه للمجله العلميه
اي ان وزن هياكل المدينه التي تشمل مبنى
كرايسلر يعادل وزن 140 مليون فيل باحثون
ابتكروا نماذج جغرافيه لقياس معدل غرق
نيويورك عن طريق عرض الضغط الهبوطي
للمباني الثقيله على الصخر والطين والرمل
وحتى الطمي اسفل بعض المنطقه هذه القياسات
اظهرت ان منهات
الافلام هي غابه خرسانيه حقيقيه ومعرضه
لخطر الغرق اكثر من مناطق نيويورك الاخرى
لاسيما ان جزءا كبيرا منها يقع الارتفاع
متر الى مترين فوق مستوى سطح البحر الحالي
في حين تشهد اجزاء من مقاطعتي بروكلين
وكوينز ايضا معدلات هبوط اعلى من اجزاء
اخرى من نيويورك اذا انخفاض مليمتر او
مليمترين سنويا قد لا يبدو كثيرا ولا ينذر
بخطر قريب لكن الباحثين حذروا من زياده
خطر الفيضانات خصوصا مع ارتفاع مستويات
سطح البحر فالمياه المحيطه بنيويورك سجلت
ارتفاعا قدره 22 سم منذ عام
1950 التربه اذا الاكثر ليونه وفق
الباحثين تزيد ضغط المباني ما يستوجب خططا
لحمايه المدينه وسكانها البالغ عددهم نحو
ثمانيه ملايين و400,000 شخص فالتعرض
المتكرر لمياه البحر قد يؤدي الى تاكل
الفولاذ وايضا زعزعه استقرار المباني
ودفعها للاسفل اكثر فاكثر اخرها كان يسار
ايضا قبل عامين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات